I see that the fact that 911 changed all
of our way of thinking it made us
realize that we were no longer an island
in the world made us realize you know
that we are part of this whole universe
much more so than ever before that
people can harm us that some people
don't like us some people out there
really despise America our way of life
our value systems and what we have to do
is we have to show the rest of the world
that our value systems and our beliefs
are good in that people may not want to
adopt them but they should look at them
and try and emulate some of the
greatness of America and I believe you
know the way forward is to do what I'm
talking about in medical diplomacy
winning the peace in Iraq and you know
you're never going to solve this problem
without really winning that piece in
Iraq
you